let's talk about the Saudis for a minute
the elephant under the Western carpet I
mean I understand that in the aftermath
of the oil crisis in the 1970s one of
the things that that dictated American
foreign policy was the desire to
maintain stable oil production and and I
can understand that although I think it
was short-sighted I can I conceded the
logic in that but it's very difficult
for me to see that in any possible way
the Saudis can be regarded as true
allies of the West and so I don't
understand why we have the relationship
that we do have with the Saudis given
first of all that we're pumping
literally trillions of doors every about
every decade into their economy and then
given that they practice a particularly
pernicious form of I would say viciously
militant Islam and second or third I
guess that is is that they're pumping
out propaganda that pushes this Wahhabi
viewpoint in massive doses everywhere in
the world I mean I don't understand and
maybe this is also part of your
perplexity with regards to Western
attitudes towards towards the complex
problem of Islam I don't understand why
the West doesn't do more to put a stop
to that and so what are your thoughts
about that how does it look to you I'm
perplexed
I believe that the Saudis have put the
United States and other Westerners under
their cell and someone has to come along
and break that I mean I agree with
everything you said within Saudi Arabia
they don't have I believe at least three
forces the whole family I believe they
want to go down on the top of the UAE
and then take larger incredibly powerful
maybe even more powerful than the whole
fund because the clergy in Saudi Arabia
they have the power to put into people's
you know heads and hearts the Wahhabi
doctrine and they're all about Saudi
Arabia
people who decide what's right or what's
wrong moral of the program right they
are that powerful and then you have the
tribes the various tribes who obviously
depending on their size can either
empower royal family for the clergy or
both there's a dynamic thing that is
very interesting to watch but in that
sense Saudi Arabia has used and has
indulged and accommodated the clergy
love order to establish is were having a
food he will Medina legacy Saudi Arabia
is a key office it's pure Medina not
only inside the borders of Saudi Arabia
but of course this entire yeah
and now I think we the United States and
other countries need to demand from the
Saudi royal family because the other
ones were political at least the
political individuals are dealing with
obesity of course want a general to
demand and say you know we need a
divorce between the house of our south
and the house of Allah because it's
clergy people are really destroying the
planet they do justice you have to think
through what these people have done in
South Asia in Africa it's the beauty of
geography like Saudi Arabia to commit
it's a part of its wealth to the spread
of Islam yes
Islam that's pure dollar that is through
institutions and this is this is their
foreign policy we probably could refer
that to a soft cloud that's where the
subtitles but that if you look at what
is happening all these terrorist
activities across the people wanting
Sharia back all of these Saudi Arabia is
behind it like this time young with yeah
okay so let me run a theory by you it's
kind of a two-fold theory so one is that
there's a paternalistic attitude in the
west towards the Saudis that stems from
perhaps events that were as far back as
a hundred years ago and the
paternalistic aspect is too
underestimate them as enemies right
because you say well we could say well
we need the oil and we're gonna
stabilize it and maybe that we'd rather
not have chaos in Saudi Arabia and so a
known dictator is better than unknown
chaos and I mean we saw some proof of
that perhaps in what happened with Libya
but so the idea would be there's nothing
sufficiently dangerous about the Saudis
to justify us destabilizing their regime
especially when we're particularly
dependent on their oil and then
underneath that would be an
underestimation of the danger of ideas
and also especially when ideas are
combined with money it's something like
that so yeah because the Saudis in some
sense I think are fighting what you
might regard as a stealth war against
the West and they're doing it by
convincing upcoming generations of the
rightness of their particular viewpoint
and so they're in it for the long haul
in some sense and I think we're
radically under estimating the danger of
that and we're not yeah I mean you have
to think of when the Soviet Union was
around if we hadn't done anything in
response if we had only viewed that in
economic terms or in military terms yeah
and that is out the way not just Saudi
Arabia disgusted our discreet is even
Iran you know these countries are waging
an ideological war and we are not
because you're here they believe well
it's religion and religion is protective
and you know we don't talk about
religion that's one thing we believe
we're under the spell of these
incredibly charming Saudis that come to
attend our universities that have their
embassies here and business with us and
that we are sure as they're more
westernized than we are we happier by
how they treat their women yeah so in a
way I think again I just keep going back
to saying we are under some sort of
spell and at some point you know someone
has to come and break that spell yeah
through more globalization to you know
Saudi Arabia opens up the world economy
we really see in our eyes what goes on
inside their own country and inside not
just not so really all these other
countries
it's the American people the Canadian
here Western people yeah pushes and say
no to this and demand from their
governments that's they engage with
sodium a be in a different way